Yeah,
that we had a big party and lab had a
lot of reporters came to get comments
from people at Harvard.
Um,
I think the,
I'm really excited and because at
Harvard,
Harvard has a lot of private funding and
so it's so some labs have projects that
are less dependent on federal funding,
but I think that lots of people in the
US,
there's thousands of universities,
many of which are very bright people
trying to advance stem cell research and
that blockading federal money to those
lab of toys.
Villi hurts us a lot because we can't
hope to bring queues into market.
I think by just having pilot funding to
universities and corporate funding for
pharmaceuticals and that I'm really
excited now that our current president
is looking forward to trying to um,
jumpstart stem cell research and
biomedical research as whole.
And I think that
as this money gets spread around the
country,
that we will see a lot of people from
different universities and institutions
publishing a lot of good work that's
really going to move us forward.
I'm really excited that this is going
on.
I think that while the first FDA trials,
clinical trials for stamps was a going
on now with spinal cord injury,
um,
that many of my colleagues and friends
and I agree that it will be decades
before this becomes a more prevalent
trend.
And I think that looking at the current,
um,
current drugs for pharmaceutical
companies,
it can take maybe on a scale of 10 years
and a billion dollars to get a drug all
the way to market.
And so I think that means that for the
stem cell studies are being done it now
in mice,
that it will take at least at the very
minimum,
a decade,
much more to be able to get those to
humans.
I think the fact is we're so comfortable
with taking pills or taking shots,
but
when gene therapy came around,
no one was too excited about putting
viruses into the body.
And I think that right now people aren't
too thrilled about putting stem cells
with stem cell derived cells into
someone's body.
And I think that
it's really important that we try to
take this slow and be careful and make
sure that nothing that we can
ultimately,
hi a person,
that these stem cells won't hurt anyone.
And I think it definitely will take
decades.
And I guess maybe as my generation gets
older,
we'll see stem cells come around because
there's a big interest in them and lots
of people interested.
But I think that it's something in the
near foreseeable future but not but
definitely not now.
And that the future was definitely going
to bring a lot.
And I'm really excited to see how it.